[Music]  when I was using I remember look at this  and I like what is it like black magnet  people come up with these buildings and  they just have no reason they just like  yeah but it works like bow why okay  Eddie has created things that will  probably change education forever and  Lee's Summit they're always you in  charge of interest you're going to say  oh that's cool I'll just pay Izzie oh  yeah I don't pay hahaha joke's on you in  just a second it's difficult to  understand really how someone in Sydney  can influence the outcomes of people  across the whole country we love him to  become either a doctor or a lawyer  certainly he could have been any one of  those things and that makes the money  but he's chosen to be a teacher I've  given you a hundreds of HSE questions  what's something you would feel  confident explaining in front of other  people  he's [ __ ] in don't say it when you're  [ __ ] into masks  [Music]